Lithium ion batteries changed our world by
delivering us hours of energy in a small lightweight
package.
But ya know what, my phone battery only lasts
a day and THAT’S NOT ENOUGH!
I NEED MORE!!!
Luckily, scientists are already on it, and
have been working for decades on a new battery
design that could could last up to 8 times
longer, leaving lithium in the dust.
Introducing: Fluoride batteries!!
Okay, before you yell at me in the comments-
NO these aren’t ready yet.
You’re not going to be able to watch this
video and then buy a fluoride battery online.
Science is slow, everything takes time, BUT
this is a huge exciting breakthrough and I
have the right to be excited.
First, a quick vocab breakdown: Fluoride is
the negative ion of the element fluorine,
that’s also why compounds containing fluorine
(like the sodium fluoride in toothpaste) are
called fluorides.
Fluoride batteries have been of interest since
the 1970s when researchers first started experimenting
with the material in solid state designs.
And though the tests only worked under extremely
high temperatures, fluoride held their interest
due to its capacity to create a battery with
a high energy density- it could store more
charge in the same amount of space.
A typical lithium-ion battery has 3 parts.
An anode and a cathode separated by an electrolyte.
As the battery discharges, positive lithium
ions flow from the anode, across the electrolyte,
into the cathode.
This leaves free electrons in the anode that
create your current.
When you charge your lithium battery, the
reverse happens- ions in the cathode flow
back into the anode.
Fluoride batteries work a little differently.
Instead of relying on the transfer of positive
lithium ions, fluoride batteries use negative
fluoride ions to generate their current.
The reason these batteries have such a high
energy density comes down to the molecular
structure of metal fluorides.
In a metal fluoride, the ratio of fluorine
atoms to metal atoms is high.
For example in copper fluoride, two fluorine
atoms are combined with just one copper atom.
That means for every copper atom, you get
two fluoride ions that can move 2 electrons.
In a typical lithium battery, however, you
only get 1 lithium atom for every two oxygens
1 cobalt.
That means for every two oxygen atoms and
1 cobalt atom there’s only one lithium ion,
that can only move 1 electron.
The copper fluoride gives you more ions that
can move more electrons-- and does it without
increasing overall mass.
That means batteries of the same weight can
hold more charge, aaaand last up to 8 times
longer.
On top of improved energy density, replacing
lithium with fluoride might also makes these
batteries less likely to overheat.
Some scientists also say the materials needed
to make a fluoride battery could be more environmentally
friendly to harvest than the lithium and cobalt
we currently use.
But all of these great benefits rest on us
being able to get fluoride batteries to work,
and until this latest breakthrough- we could
only really do that with solid electrolytes
that functioned upwards of 150 degrees celsius.
Now though, scientists NASA, Caltech, and
Honda have developed a new flouride-conducting
liquid electrolyte that functions at room
temperature.
They paired it with a copper lanthanum trifluoride
cathode and a metal anode, and created a prototype
fluoride battery that discharged-- and recharged(!!)-
at room temperature.
It’s a big deal, y’all.
Buuut now for the reason why you can’t buy
them yet.
This concept proved room temperature fluoride
batteries are possible, but they’ll still
need to be tinkered with and streamlined to
get that super high energy density they promise.
There are also some other complications that
need to be worked out, like the fact that
a complicated coating is required so the electrolyte
doesn’t literally dissolve the metal electrode.
All of that aside, it is a HUGE step towards
a functional, scalable fluoride battery.
And while it will take time to work out the
kinks, this could be the start of a whole
new era for energy storage- and I for one
am *HERE *FOR*IT*!
While we wait for fluoride batteries, why
don’t you put those lithium ones to good
use by building your very own website!
Domain dot com has all your website needs,
including dot com and dot net domain names
and intuitive website builders.These guys
are awesome - they’re affordable, reliable,
and have all the tools you need to build a
new website.
And if you want to brand yourself online,
Domain dot com has over three hundred domain
extensions to fit your needs, from dot pizza
to dot space.
The guys at Domain dot com love Elements,
and to show their love they’re giving you
20% off their already affordable prices.
Use coupon code ELEMENTS at Domain dot com’s
checkout for 20% off.
When you think domain names, think Domain
dot com.
You can’t give your friends a fluoride battery,
but you can give them a cool science t-shirt!
Check out our new Teespring store below the
description where you can find this shirt,
and other awesome science themed designs.
For more on batteries, check out this playlist,
and don’t forget to subscribe for all the
best battery news.
Thanks for watching!